-How's everyone doing tonight?
A little angry at me
for even asking? That's fair
Well, I will just say that
while I am not good,
I am better for
being here with you.
Now let's get to the news.
President Trump had lunch with
Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo today.
Pompeo ordered the chicken
and Trump ordered the tear
gassing of peaceful protesters
President Trump
tweeted yesterday
that the Republican
National Convention
will not be held in Charlott
because of
social-distancing restrictions
put in place by North Carolina
governor Roy Cooper.
So now the only place left i
that pool in the Ozarks.
[ As Trump ] Now I'd like
to introduce our next speaker,
Mike Pompeo.
Swim on up here, Mike.
Here he comes, splashing around.
Not the best swimmer,
but he's making his way.
Let's just -- If we could just
move our inner tubes
to the side to make a path
a channel."
[ Normal voice ] President Trump
claimed on Twitter yesterday
that his administration ha
"done more for
the black community
than any president since
Abraham Lincoln."
Are you serious?
You've been terrible
for the black community.
That's like Godzilla
bragging he's done a lot
for the Japanese community
When asked by reporters
yesterday if President Trump
was projecting calm
to the country,
Republican senator John Thun
said Trump "has moments."
Damn, that's what you say abou
someone on their deathbed.
"Have you visited grandpa?
How's he doing?"
"Well, you know,
he, uh...he has moments."
Republican congressman and
white supremacist Steve King
lost his race in
yesterday's Iowa primary,
which is tough for King,
because his race is like
his favorite thing.
He famously loves it.
Former Vice President Joe Bide
spoke in Philadelphia yesterda
and criticized President Trump's
response to the protests
against police violence
across the country.
Said Biden, "If anyone's going
to act racist in this country,
it's going to be me,
accidentally."
According to a new poll,
53% of American office workers
worry that their current skill
will be outdated
in fewer than five years,
skills like no-pants
budget meetings.
Royal Caribbean
has announced that,
due to coronavirus
travel restrictions
by the Canadian government
it has canceled all cruise
that pass through Canada
through October.
So if you planned to take
a cruise to Canada in October,
you're doing cruises wrong
I think?
I'm not an expert, but...
Today was National Egg Day
which comes before
National Chicken Day.
But wait.
Chicken Day happened last year
which came after Egg Day,
which came before -- Damn it
Karen Chee, everybody.
When the news is dark, you can
count on America's sweetheart,
Karen Chee, to write you a jok
about National Egg Day.
Thank you, Karen.
I miss seeing you.
Today was also --
today was also -- Excuse me.
I'm on an Egg Day high.
Today was also
National Tailors' Day
or sew it seams.
Mike Scollins,
you can [bleep] right off.
You know what?
Show me a picture of
Karen again.
"Sew it seams."
Hi, Karen.
And, finally,
researchers now believe
that having sex with someone you
are not quarantining with
can increase your risk of
getting the coronavirus,
unless, of course,
you're an essential worker
Mike Scollins again.
You won me back, buddy.
Throw Mike up there
and let the people see Mike.
There he is.
That was a monologue.